[Music]
my name is macy and i am a jeweler at
beijing vintage
i am going to walk you through how to
restore a 1930s art deco ring
this ring is a 14 karat yellow gold
setting the gemstone in this ring is a
created spinel stone
the biggest things wrong with this ring
were the misshapen band there's a
resizing bar at the bottom of the ring
band from a previous resizing and then
the gemstone will need to be replaced if
it's not in any salvageable condition
this ring
might probably only be worth maybe a
hundred dollars and when we're finished
this ring might sell for about four to
five thousand dollars
[Music]
the first thing that i will do with any
restoration is to take out any gemstones
that can't be saved there's a large part
on the underside of the stone that had
cracked off
i'm getting rid of the resizing band
because oftentimes especially in vintage
and antique pieces the resizing was
often poorly done
this tool is called a jeweler saw and
i'm using this to cut out the sizing bar
rather than unsoldering it just because
i was having some trouble on soldering
it so just to be safe and
eliminate the chance of accidentally
melting the whole ring while trying to
unsolder it i just decided to cut it out
soldering is a process of joining two
pieces of metal with solder and that
solder can be either silver solder or
gold solder
when i remove that piece of metal
solder will only flow if it's a perfect
seam so once i
cut the sizing bar out i have to file
the ends so they're perfectly parallel
to each other so that when i close that
seam there's no
air in between so that the solder can
flow
i am hammering the seam shut so i'm
trying to
close those two ends together even if
the ring band isn't perfectly round that
can always be fixed later as long as
those two ends are touching each other
to get them ready to be soldered back
together and then i take the ring to my
soldering bench and i'm going to prep
the ring for soldering
i apply what is called flux and flux
will prevent any oxides that will form
on the surface of the ring while being
soldered from the torch from building up
and then adding my gold solder to the
seam where i intend to have it flow then
i'm going to be using a 14 karat gold
solder which is essentially just an
alloy of gold and also zinc and zinc is
what makes the metal
melt at a low temperature so it allows
the solder to flow into the seam of what
i'm trying to connect and it will bind
those two pieces together permanently
and then i use my torch to evenly heat
up the piece in order to get the solder
up to
its melting temperature
the prongs on this ring are cracked and
worn from age they just need a little
bit of reinforcement i add some solder
to the prongs to give them some extra
thickness so i can create a new seat
later on in the process for the stone
once i'm finished with the prongs i take
the ring back to my bench and remove
some of the extra solder material from
the inside of the ring band i use
a tool called a flex shaft with a
silicone bit and that's going to remove
some of the material from the solder
seam so that when i hammer it round
again the solder doesn't
embed itself into the metal
once that material is mostly removed i
move on to hammering a
round shape back into the ring with a
rawhide mallet and a steel ring mandrel
and since the steel ring mandrel is
tapered to accommodate for all different
kinds of sizes of rings i
frequently flip back and forth and work
from both sides to make sure that one
side is not
larger than the other side and i work
from all sides of the piece except for
on the ring head because i don't want to
deform the head of the ring
once i'm done
rounding the band back out i go ahead
and i start removing some of the solder
from the outside of the band and i use
this with a hand file and then once i'm
finished with a hand file i start using
some silicone
polishing wheels with my boredom flex
shaft to further remove some of the
scratches and begin the process of
starting to polish the piece i go
through a process of four different
abrasivenesses starting from the most
coarse to the finest to get the bulk of
the polishing done on the outside of the
beef
once i'm done working on the ring band i
move on to polishing the inside of the
ring starting with a polishing compound
that's called white diamond and this is
an abrasive polishing compound so even
though it's polishing it still removes
material from the surface of the metal
and then after that i move on to a
polishing compound called fabuluster
which is a polishing compound that is
very tiny clay bits so it kind of brings
out the really luster high polish finish
to the metal
and once i'm done with that i repeat the
entire process on the outside of the
ring so that i can
get the ring back to a mirror finish
like it should be
[Music]
once i'm done with polishing
i move on to getting the stone ready to
be set
[Music]
i'm replacing the created spinel with a
diamond because it's a large enough
setting that it would make a really nice
engagement ring it's a solid ring
setting
this diamond is 1.3 carats
to prepare for the diamond to be set i
kind of evaluate where all the prongs
are at i make sure that they're all even
they're all nice and reinforced from the
stuttering that i have already done
and i start to carve out
the material with
some setting burrs and bulburs to try
and create a more perfect seat for the
diamond to sit in
once that's done i use a little bit of
wax to place the stone
into the ring setting
and from there this is a good fit i'm
ready to start pushing the prongs over
and so i
use a tool that is called a bezel pusher
to start to push over the prongs to hold
the diamond in place
[Music]
we are so happy with how this ring came
out
and we're so happy to give it a second
life
[Music]
you